and let's bring in Dave Rubin host of
the Rubin report Dave I mean it's one
thing to have a rally where you're in
support of somebody these Pro
Palestinian rallies are happening all
across the country but so many of them
are permeated with anti-Semitism and as
we saw in California a Jewish man died
in an altercation in one of these
protests yeah let me be clear John I
speak for myself not for Fox Rashida TB
is a Hamas supporter and when she says
River to the Sea she means the mination
of Israel which would be about 8 million
Jews a second Holocaust and you'd have
to kill about 2 million Arab Muslims who
live in Israel and BNS and bahai and
Christians and others uh but that would
be just fine for her it would be just
fine for many of these people uh
protesting you know they're also calling
for the end of the occupation which they
claim began in 1948 well that means they
want to bring the British Empire back I
suppose we could go back 250 years and
bring back the Ottoman Empire because
there never was a state of Palestine as
anyone who knows history knows uh look
this is the Rabid genocidal movement of
our time it it is just true it's hard to
say but it is just true there is nothing
Israel can do other than layover and die
that would satiate either the Hamas
caucus right here AOC Talib Cory Bush
Etc or or those people out on the
streets there was no occupation of Gaza
the day before all of this on October
6th not one Jew Liv there not one
Israeli live there Hitler would have
loved the place every year or so they
would lob Rockets over and Israel would
have to respond to those Rockets they
went in they killed 15,000 people the
barbaric medieval uh horrific torture
that they did they still have 200 people
they have 12 Americans at least why is
nobody in America calling for
unconditional release of American
hostages if you don't at least care
about the Israelis uh look the the enemy
is in our borders we all know it and
until we all level up and figure out how
we are going to fight this properly it
is just going to get worse and worse we
have video it's the White House they
have video of who desecrated the White
House and put the paint on the walls why
haven't they done anything about that
New York City where I used to live when
they're going after cop cars and
painting free Gaza all over the cop cars
do they not have video of those people
we have facial recognition software and
everything else we have every tool we we
need to deal with all of this but do we
have the political will that's really
what this is all about yeah vandalism is
really getting a pass these days it
would seem they're also in a lot of
these rallies
are a lot of people who conflate the
Palestinians and Hamas at a at a protest
in London people were openly supporting
Hamas calling them Freedom Fighters and
then one organization did some
interviews with people there and there
didn't seem to be a whole lot of
knowledge about what Hamas is really all
about listen to this sound right
here when Hamas invaded Israel on the
7th of October what was your initial
reaction to them I don't believe they
did itday H uh I think so I honestly
like I think I need to be a bit more
clued up on like everything that's going
on I'm at the rally but I don't know
what the heck is going on and I need to
get clued up on it what does that tell
you well it tells you that these rallies
are a very strange conflation of a
couple thing I think you have the true
radicals and the islamists and the
people that are more in line cognitively
let's say with Rashida to then you have
just sort of the intersectional leftists
that are basically the remnants of BL M
and of course BLM which was a complete
fraudulent organization that never sent
a black kid to college or opened a black
business or anything like that uh
they've just ripped the mask off
literally and figuratively and they've
become a pramas organization so a lot of
these college kids notice there aren't
families out there there aren't
middle-aged generally speaking
middle-aged well-dressed people who seem
like functional members of societies
it's young single people who have have
their brains mashed by Tik Tock and by
modern Academia and they have no idea
they have no idea what they're talking
about if you don't think the Jews have a
little something to do with Israel might
you if you don't care about reading
history how about learn the story of
Hanukkah do you know where Jesus was
from it was called Judea back then we
call it the West Bank now so unless you
think Jesus has nothing to do with the
Holy Land uh you should be at one of
these rallies you know I don't imagine
that many of the people who are at these
rallies have have seen the video footage
that Israel put together and has been
presenting to the media in special
screenings it's the unedited video that
was taken mostly by Hamas from the
October simp would care yeah well well I
don't know but maybe they would they
simply wouldn't care listen to this
description from Sabrina mat who is a
reporter for the National Post who
watched this she said I watched Hamas
hack Innocents to death the worst part
was their Glee screen footage showed
literal streams of blood hacked off arms
and legs and an infant missing part of
its skull brain leaking out I'll never
forget the gore but it's the look of
euphoria and pride in the terrorist's
eyes cheering for the cameras as if they
were the ones partying in a music
festival that day that will haunt me how
how how can a normally functioning human
being not look at that and say what an
ungodly Act of Terror and why would you
support the people behind
it John you know at least in the 1930s
the Nazis who filmed a lot of their
atres had the temerity to hide it right
they were filming it for their own
records but they were trying to hide it
from the rest of the world because had
the rest of the world known at least a
little more quickly than ultimately they
found out they might have done some
things to stop it hamas's reason their
cause for existence is to try to kill as
many people as possible not only Israeli
though but also Palestinian because as
we know they obviously use Palestinians
as human Shields and they shoot from
kindergartens and from mosques and from
un facilities and everywhere else so
they want utter Mayhem and destruction
there is nothing the Israelis can do
other than die that would make these
people happy but the history of the Jews
yes a lot of people get killed in the
history of the Jews but the Jews are
still here and that's what Hamas
ultimately will find out at the end of
this thing unfortunately but I would say
to the average American that's watching
this and maybe doesn't care about the
Middle East or doesn't particularly care
one way or another about Jews which is
just fine and everything else if you
think that these people who are Marching
in Times Square and in DC and in
Brussels and Paris and everywhere else
London Etc if you think they will be
done they will magically be done with
their Quest once they eliminate the Jews
uh no that will be the beginning of the
quest because the real Quest is to take
out America it is to take out every
Western Civilization if they can
disconnect the Jews from the ancient
land of Israel what do you think they're
going to think about America and our 250
year old history you don't have to ask
me and you don't have to ask you just
listen to them about what they think of
this country so we better wisen up and
wisen up quickly Dave rubit good to get
your thoughts troubling though they
might be appreciate it thank
you